>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Sandra Charles: This morning,
we have truly a remarkable panel.
This is really the panel.
We don't have all of them
but this is the panel.
Ellen Sigal from Friends
of Cancer Research.
Dr. Louis Weiner-- Weiner, thank
you-- from Georgetown University,
Lombardi Comprehensive
Cancer Center.
All members of the Task Force
and the Blue Ribbon Panel
and two other people coming,
Dr. Singer and Dr. Lowy.
Dr. Lowy is the acting director
of the National Cancer Institute,
the agency that was basically
charged getting this together.
And Dr. Singer is the
Acting Deputy Director.
And so, you see we really have a
good set of people to enlighten us
and make us understand
how this is going
to affect us and change our lives.
I think we'll hear from Vice
President Biden, who was appointed
to lead this whole initiative by
the president, as many of you may
or may recall, in his State of
the Union Address back in January.
And I thought, who better to lead
us of and give us an overview
but Vice President Biden, so--
>> Joe Biden: Hi, everybody.
This is Joe Biden.
I got a delivery report to President
Obama laying out how far we've come
since he put me in charge
of the Cancer Moonshot
that was back in January.
And to lay out a real vision
for where we need to go
in the immediate future to do
in five years what otherwise would
take 10, to inject the real sense
of urgency into the fight against
cancer, and to change the culture
and reimagine our system
in order to be able to win.
You know, when President Nixon
declared a war on cancer in 1971,
he had no army, he had no
resources, and no clear strategy.
But after 45 years of
progress, funding research,
training scientists and
physicians, and treating millions
of patients, we now have an army.
And we have tools, powerful tools.
And with the Moonshot, we now have
a clear strategy for the road ahead.
It matters, folks, because
there's a consensus now that we're
at an inflection point with
science, medicine, technology,
all advancing faster than ever
and offering real promise.
We can't play by the rules in 1971.
We didn't have this working for us.
In 2016, there's much
more we can do.
Just five years ago, for
example, immunotherapy,
using the immune system
to kill cancer cells while
protecting healthy ones,
wasn't taken seriously.
Now it is and it's working
with other disciplines
and offering real hope.
Decades of research have
accumulated large amounts of data,
but that data is not shared,
it's hard to understand.
It is often not accessible to
researchers and the public.
But now we're in the position
to break down these silos
and share it all, because
we have an enormous capacity
with computing capability
to take millions
of pieces of data and analyze it.
We can do a million billion
calculations per second now.
And the Moonshot's vision report
reflects what my wife and I,
Jill and I, have learned
after meeting with thousands
of cancer patients, their families,
advocates, physicians, researchers,
philanthropists, technology leaders,
and heads of states from all
over the world what we need to do.
We have to do everything from
enhancing prevention efforts,
expanding access to care, forging
an international commitment
to fight cancer.
This week, I also released
a report on--
from a Cancer Moonshot Task
Force, the team I'm leading
to reimagine the federal
government's fight
against this dreaded disease.
>> Sandra Charles: OK.
So, you heard it from
the VP himself.
>> Joe Biden: It touches
almost every corner
of the government, for example.
>> Sandra Charles: He had
more to say but we thought
that what we played would set
the stage for our discussion.
And to extend our warm
hospitality and welcome,
I have the Deputy Librarian of
Congress, Mr. Robert Newlen,
is here to extend that welcome
and some opening remarks.
>> Robert Newlen: Well,
good morning everyone.
It's my pleasure to welcome you
on behalf of the 14th Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden
to the Library of Congress.
And I'm not making this up.
One of her top priorities is to
improve the visitor experience.
[ Laughter ]
What was the prior--
Dr. Hayden has had her own
experiences in the library,
navigating everything from parking
to exhibits, and this is something
that she's talked a great deal about
and is really doing something about.
In fact, we have just hired--
he'll be arriving in February--
an expert in museum visitor services
and how visitors, you
know, interact.
And-- So, I think we have a
great focus here for the future.
So, I sympathize with you and
we're going to try and improve it.
It's very nice to be addressing
a sober audience today.
As deputy librarian,
I have the privilege
of opening many conferences
not unlike this.
And last week, I opened a symposium
for the American Folklife Center
and they were celebrating
Kentucky Folklife
with an emphasis on
Kentucky bourbon.
And during the program, they had
a variety of Kentucky bourbons,
everything from Wild
Turkey to Maker's Mark,
and everybody was sampling
all the different bourbons.
So, by the time I got up, I
could have read the phonebook
and they would've applauded.
So, it's nice to have this
great attentive audience today.
The Library of Congress
has, as you probably know,
an incredible collection
of treasures.
Right now, we number just
about 162 million items,
everything from books,
manuscripts, films, recordings,
you name it we've got it.
And I hope if this is your
first visit to the library
that you'll have a chance to
explore it, either online.
We have a new website up.
It's really-- I have
to say I love it.
It's really great,
much more accessible.
So I hope you'll be visiting
that but also visiting one
of our three buildings here, because
it is an incredible institution.
But while we talk about
these treasures,
really the greatest treasure
we have here at the Library
of Congress is the staff.
The staff are just incredible from
everything, from our curators,
librarians, attorneys, experts,
just an incredible group of staff.
But one of the treasures
that I specially treasure
is Dr. Sandra Charles.
And I can't tell you how grateful we
all are at the Library of Congress
for her leadership of health
services, for being proactive
to attract events like this
to the Library of Congress.
So, Dr. Charles, I just want
to tell you how much I appreciate
the wonderful work you do
for all the staff of
the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
I've been waiting for a moment to
do that, so I'm glad I could do it.
Last night, I downloaded the
report because I wanted to read it.
And I found it to be a
really fascinating report,
but also for a layperson
like myself, very accessible.
And I was also impressed with
the kinds of recommendations
that were coming out of the report,
things that are very practical,
that are very specific.
And, you know, one
can't help but think
of one's own experience with cancer.
Both of my parents died of
cancer, my father of liver cancer
and my mother of lung cancer.
So, Strategic Goal 4 was one
that really jumped out at me,
and that was strengthen
prevention and diagnosis.
And I thought, you know,
if my parents had been able
to take advantage of some of
the things that are recommended
in this report, their cancers
might have been caught earlier
or they might have had
better care at that time.
So, I was just-- I can't tell you
how impressed I was with the report
and the impact that it had on me.
We're so very grateful
that the key members
of the Cancer Moonshot Task Force
and Blue Ribbon Panel agreed
to participate in this
panel discussion today.
And I'm happy to see some
congregational colleagues here
and policy experts.
I see some folks from embassy.
So, I'm really delighted that
this is also being videotaped
so that we can share it with
others and take advantage
of this great expertise that
we have with the panel today.
Vice President Biden's
initiative is really a good example
of new developments
in science policy
and the so-called convergence.
The idea, as I understand
it, is to break down walls
between scientific specialties and
create a dialogue among scientists
in different disciplines.
So, this panel is certainly
one of those efforts.
I want to read a quote,
it's very appropriate.
We just had this videotape
of Vice President Biden.
But one of his quotes that
struck me particularly was,
"We sought to better understand and
break down the silos and stovepipes
that prevent the sharing of
information and impedes advances
in cancer research and treatment
while building a focused
and coordinated effort
at home and abroad."
So again, thank you to the panelists
and I know everyone is going
to enjoy this panel today.
And thank you for being here.
>> Sandra Charles: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, you see, you got a good
old-fashioned library welcome.
You learned some billings we
didn't intend to show you today.
And you will have to come back
after March when our expert comes
on board then you'll
see the new experience.
[ Laughter ]
So, I have to say that when the
news of the Moonshot came out,
it immediately got to my radar.
And I wanted to make sure I
could bring it to the library
and to share it because that
strategy that Mr. Newlen mentioned,
having to do with prevention,
is precisely what we are
about in health services.
And so, what we have done over the
past few years is to bring in many--
as many partners as we can in
order to get our programs going.
One such partner-- Or
actually we have a committee
of such partners comprising library
employees, but one such partner,
who is the chair of that
Wellness Advisory Committee,
which is what we call
it, is Juanita Lyle.
And she is a bundle of energy.
She tags people as she calls it.
And before you know
it, you're just tagged
and you're just doing
so many things.
So when I expressed to Juanita what
one of our dreams was or our vision,
she said I think I got this.
And sure enough, she looked at
the panel, recognized the name
from the panel, this wonderful Dr.
Sigal to my right, left, center.
[ Laughter ]
And we got on a telephone
conversation and here we are.
So, I'd like to bring Juanita
up just to give some perspective
as a cancer advocate
about the initiative.
And Juanita will tell
you but I'll tell you too
because I'm so impressed by her.
She is a four-time cancer survivor
and started when we didn't have much
to offer at all for breast
cancer in particular.
So, she really is a testament
to so many things scientific
and so many things
just natural order.
So Juanita, would you please
come and give your perspective.
[ Applause ]
>> Juanita Lyle: Hi, everybody.
This for me is the beginning of a
new day, beginning of a new time
in the history of cancer.
You see, I am the past history of
cancer because I was back in the day
when none of these was happening.
In 1976, I was diagnosed with
a third stage breast cancer.
And I was only at that time-- So now
everybody knows my age, but now--
at that time I was only 32.
And so, I was in the time where
it was old woman's disease,
not a young woman's disease.
So today, this year, is
actually my 40th year anniversary
since my first diagnosis.
I had my first reoccurrence in
1980, my second reoccurrence in 1981
that had gone from
localized to regional.
I had diagnosed actually both of my
reoccurrences and I've had a total
of eight biopsies in
which four were negative.
So, back then, when
I had my diagnosis,
I came into my doctor's office and I
told him, "OK, this is back again."
And he looked at me
and he said, "Oh."
And it just so happened that
it went back to the same place
if the decisive search we did-- I
had at that time because it had gone
into the lymph nodes of my--
lymph nodes that I had
were already infected
with seven lymph nodes filled
with the cancer up in 19
that were removed and the size
of almost 5-centimeter
large tumor that I had.
So, here I was the second time
and I came back to him and I said,
"This crap is back again."
And he kind of looked at me and
he says, "No, it couldn't be.
You've had two years of--
You've had three years
of two different protocols
of chemotherapy
and you had a year tamoxifen,
so how is this possible?"
And he sat there and he fell and he
actually cried and fell apart on me.
And I swayed him, "Get
this straight,
I am the patient, you're the doctor.
You need to get this straight."
So here I was after three years--
So here I am after three
years of chemotherapy,
three months radiation, a
year tamoxifen, and three--
and that I had-- Here back then
at that time I had a six-year-old
daughter and an eight-year-old son.
So they watched me fight
cancer from 1976 to 1982.
I didn't even get past
to five years.
I also consented to a
clinical trial, which--
of which I was the only
African-American to actually be
in that clinical trial
in 1976-- '77.
So, I've lived with many challenges
in the aftermath of cancer.
Because back then, there
wasn't any monitoring of--
one of the things that
Moonshot is going to be doing,
there was not any monitoring of
how cancer, your chemotherapy
and your radiation was done
because it was all about--
back then, about the
disease that the person had,
not the person who had the disease.
So they did everything to
try to get rid of the disease
but the same time, it ended up with
us doing time with other things
down the road for the
aftermath of cancer.
I had to create my own
patient navigator system
because there wasn't any.
There was not a patient
navigator program.
What was really kind of ironic
about that, a couple years ago,
this is a quite a few years ago when
I had been chosen in 2001 to be one
of NCI's CARRA members, which
is called Consumer Advocates
for Research and Related Activities.
I had a chance to work on the
first African-American patient
navigator workbook.
So that was kind of an
ironic because I was coming
in with experience from what
had happened to me of figuring
out how I could pull
all my doctors together,
how I could pull all them together
to say, OK, they're doing--
she is doing this,
they're doing that.
Here I was pulling together
my own navigation system.
So, all of what has been happening
with Cancer Moonshot are all the
things that I had been preaching
to so many people for so many
years about looking at the patient
and not looking at the
disease as the whole ball game.
So today, this is a really good--
this is incredible day with me.
Unfortunately, in my life, my sister
ended up getting cancer three times
but she got tired of the fight.
She got tired of the unknown,
the unexpected, and uncertainty
that cancer creates in our lives.
She ended up-- She actually had
cancer in between the first time,
in between my first
and second cancer.
And back then, it was
shameful to have cancer
because everybody thought
that you had done something.
I hadn't done anything.
I was a person that ate
right, that did the exercise,
that did everything right but yet
I've turned up to have cancer.
My late grandma died
of ovarian cancer.
But they thought that
that was a cancer,
that was a possible family history.
Recently, I had a genetic testing
of 32 of my genes and they found
that not one single of
my genes were mutated.
So, therefore, they had to
rule out, family history.
So, how I got it, I don't know.
But I haven't been trained as
a scientist or as a doctor,
but what I have been trained to do
is to walk in the shoes of cancer.
So today, I say thank you Ellen for
taking the call and I say thank you
to Dr. Charles who challenges me
and encourages me with her knowledge
of doctor extraordinaire,
who shares my vision for all
to stay well and have better health.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Charles:
Thank you, Juanita.
And although your program
says I'm going
to give you my perspective
again, I won't do that.
I will call on our panelists.
And it's fitting also that Juanita,
as an advocate for patients,
precedes our first speaker who is
Ellen Sigal, who is both Founder
and Chairperson of
Friends of Cancer Research.
And so, she is a member
of the Blue Ribbon Panel.
And in her role as a cancer
advocate, she will explain to us
and discuss the recently passed and
signed bipartisan Cancer Cures Act.
And also talk about
some of the issues
that have been raised regarding some
of the recommendations
vis-à-vis the FDA and others.
So Ellen, without further
ado, your slides--
excuse me, the slides will
be up and please come up.
>> Ellen Sigal: Well, thank you.
It's an honor to be here.
And Juanita, what a story.
What a story, what an
inspiration you are.
As we all know, it is about the
patient and it's about the journey
that they go through and their
family and how personal it is.
So, we care deeply about the science
but people get cancer and worth--
there is none of us that are not
affected by generally started also
on a personal loss with my sister.
So, this week is a
really special week.
This is a very special work-- week.
The 21st Century Cures
bill was passed.
We were lucky.
Many of us were there
at the White House
to see President Obama
signed the bill.
My task today is to talk a
little bit about other components
of the bill because you have
experts that will talk specifically
about the Moonshot but there's a
lot more to it than the Moonshot,
although we are cancer advocates and
we're cancer people in this room.
But this happens also
because of leadership.
The Moonshot really came out of
a personal and devastating loss
for Vice President Biden.
You know, the loss-- any
loss is tragic but the loss
of seeing your child die is probably
the worst thing that any parent
or anyone can really sustain.
So it was his leadership,
his passion,
and energy that really
got us to the Moonshot.
So, I will go through a
few of the other components
and then you will hear in detail
about the Blue Ribbon Panel.
And I was very honored
to serve on it.
One of the things that we all
know is that research is crucial.
We cannot help patients
without research.
And although we've invested a
lot, there's a lot more to do.
When we declared the war on cancer,
we thought it was one disease,
now it's hundreds of diseases.
And we've accomplished a great
deal, but to really continue,
we really need to invest
in research.
And the research funding
has been really declining
for many, many, many years.
So this truly will help us get
young scientists and get people
into research and this
is really a very, very,
very important component of it.
And not only will it have
1.8 billion for the Moonshot
for the research, it will have
many for a precision medicine
and for the brain initiative
and opioid addictions,
so there are many other things.
But there is more to
this than the research.
It's helped also the
regulatory agency, the FDA.
Before a patient gets a treatment,
it has to be approved by the FDA.
And one of the important elements
of this bill is the Office
of Cancer Oncology, the
consolidation of the cancer at FDA.
Before this, it was in three
divisions, it was in CeBER,
which was really biologics,
drugs, and CDRH.
Now, all clinical decisions will
be made by oncology experts.
And that's really important,
although it's really important
to know about antibodies and
vaccines and diagnostics.
We want these decisions to
really be made by people
who really have treated this
disease in the natural history,
and there will be resources
for this.
The Office of Oncology will have
75 million over a period of years
and the FDA will have 500 million
and there will be many,
many, many things.
One of the things that are
really important in this,
which I'm sure Dinah and Dr. Lowy
will cover, is the High-Risk,
High-Reward Research, because
that's really important.
We don't always get it right
and we want a young workforce
and we want people to really
be audacious about ideas.
Young scientists are crucial.
We can't have a pipeline
and we can't develop
these answers overnight
and having people enter science
and have ways for them to come
into science and to be attracted
and to keep them is really crucial.
One of the other parts of
this bill that I'm very proud
of is patient-centered
drug development.
And what that really means is
really getting patient's priorities.
Everybody wants to live, everybody.
And they want treatments
that will help them
but they also want quality of life.
They want to know things
that are important to them.
You know, is it toxic?
You know, will I feel a lot o pain?
Will it handle my nausea?
Will it handle things that
are most important to me?
So, we tolerate a lot of toxicity
in cancer because we have to
and we understand there's
a lot of risk.
But we want the ability to really
understand the human experience
and what it is like.
Because if you have three
months or six months or a year,
those months are really
important to you
and the quality is important also.
So, the idea of understanding
patient's needs,
patient's priorities,
is really important.
I think I don't know how
to advance my slides.
Oh, sorry.
OK, OK. I'm not going to go through
some of the technical things,
the precision biomarker
qualification but it really means
that when you start to really-- and
this will be done by NCI and others,
you really want to be able
to understand specific genetic
mutations and really targets.
Because, right, you know, we
used to treat breast cancer,
we used to treat prostate cancer.
Now we know it's all genetic.
We know that these
targets are important
and the disease is different.
When we treated breast cancer, we--
why would one survive
and one didn't?
I mean, now those are
scientific issues
that are going to be important.
Accelerating drug development
is important.
Also, the approval of drugs for
limited populations that really has
to do more with the
antibiotic resistance,
but we know that that's
really important.
Keeping and recruiting the
brightest and the best.
And I want to go through a few
other minor things before I turn it
over to my colleagues, who will give
you the specific recommendations
of the Blue Ribbon.
The-- Let's see what I have,
the streamlined data review,
priority review for breakthrough
devices is really important
because the idea is right now, we
have genetic testing and we really--
and we need to make sure
that's accurate and we want
to make sure we get--
that we understand how to
really diagnose people.
Everyone focuses on the
drug and the treatment
and not a lot on the diagnostic.
But today, these genetic
panels and these assays
that one uses is really
important in getting better ones
that are more specific on
the market is important.
So, just before I pass it over
to my wonderful colleagues,
I do want to say that when we
were appointed and Dr. Singer was
in charge of this, and we all
said, "How is this going to happen?
How 26, 28 desperate people
going to come and advance cancer
and give recommendations
in five, six months?
And the goal of the Blue Ribbon
was really to create improvements
that would have normally
taken 10 years in 5.
And I think the first meeting
we were all scratching our head.
And I think for Dr. Singer,
who is also very challenging
and Dr. Lowy how we're
going to do this.
But everyone came together.
Everyone understood the importance
of the mission and the opportunity.
And I'm very proud of the
report that was written
and I know it will
profoundly impact patients.
And, really, special, special
thanks for putting it together.
It was day, it was night, it was 7--
24/7, but everyone
understood the urgency.
And also this drug passed
overwhelmingly, you know,
this bill in the House and
the Senate was bipartisan
and in these days in Washington
where the environment is toxic,
to really see the enthusiasm,
enthusiasm for this was wonderful.
So, I'm very honored to be here.
I'm inspired by you, Juanita,
and your incredible story.
And keep on fighting and keep
on doing the right thing.
And we were-- all trying very hard.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Charles:
Thank you, Dr. Sigal.
The next two panels who will come,
first, Dr. Singer, will come forth
and she will give a broad
overview of the Moonshot Initiative
and the panel recommendations.
And then Dr. Lowy will highlight
certain specific recommendations
relating to the various kinds of
research starting with the basic
and then discussing implementation
and how they relate to
the cancer patients.
We have the bios of our
speakers in your program.
And as I mentioned, just before
they came in, Dr. Singer is--
she's the Director of the
Division of Cancer Biology
at the National Cancer
Institute, which is a part
of National Institutes of Health.
And since 1999, while simultaneously
serving as Senior Investigator
and Chief of the Molecular
Regulation Section
of the Experimental
Immunology Branch, she--
position she's had since 1991.
She's currently serving also
as Acting Deputy Director
of National Cancer Institute.
And you can see more
details in your program.
Dr. Lowy is Acting Director of
the National Cancer Institute
and also Chief of the intramural
Laboratory of Cellular Oncology
in the Center for Cancer
Research there at NCI.
And his medical degree
comes from NYU-- Yes, NYU.
And then his internal medicine
residence is at Stanford University.
He also did a dermatology
residence at Yale University.
And Stanford is one of those
places near and dear to me
as I have two daughters
who are alumna.
So, I really look forward to
hearing from, first, Dr. Singer
and then Dr. Lowy, about the
actual Moonshot Initiative.
Please come.
>> Dinah Singer: Well, thank you.
I'm delighted to be here.
Despite our somewhat late arrival,
we did get a scenic
tour of the library.
A little bit rushed but we're hoping
to come back for a longer tour.
I would like to also thank Dr.
Charles for organizing this meeting,
giving us the opportunity to
tell you about the Moonshot.
But before I start, I do want
to particularly acknowledge
Ellen Sigal,
because without her
tireless efforts,
the Cures Act would
have never happened,
the Moonshot would
have never happen.
And we're all very indebted to you,
so a round of applause for Ellen.
[ Applause ]
So now that the Cures
Act has passed,
what I would like to do is
give you a very brief overview
of the scientific components
of the Cancer Moonshot.
As Ellen pointed our, the
Cures Act encompasses more
than just the cancer research.
And in fact, the Moonshot
encompasses more than the science
but what I'm going to
focus on is the science.
So, the Moonshot actually
was launched, if you will,
during President Obama's last
State of the Union Address,
when he announced a Cancer
Moonshot effort and follow that up
with an official presidential memo
that outlined what that Moonshot was
and what it was intended
to accomplish.
I've summarized the main points here
on this slide, which is, number one,
to accelerate progress in cancer
including prevention and screening
and expanding the gamut of research
from basic research all the way
up through standard of care.
Second main area was to
encourage greater cooperation
and collaboration across
the entire cancer community
and to enhance data sharing.
So, the effort, really,
was instantiated
through a federal taskforce,
which is run out of the
Vice President's office
with the Vice President as Chair
of the taskforce that consist
of the heads of all of the
agencies in the government
that do anything associated with
cancer and including the heads
of NCI in this case, Dr.
Lowy, and NIH, Dr. Collins.
And within the presidential memo,
the NCI and its advisory broad,
the National Cancer Advisory
Board, were specifically tasked
with organizing a Blue Ribbon Panel
that would advice the
Moonshot effort
as to the scientific opportunities.
So, the specific charge in
the presidential memo was
that a Blue Ribbon Panel be
established to provide expert advice
on the vision, proposed
scientific goals,
and implementation of
the Cancer Moonshot.
And it was also charged with
providing an intensive examination
of the opportunities and
impediments in cancer research.
What the memo didn't say, but
Ellen alluded to, was that we had
to do all that in five months.
The panel itself had 28 members.
The members really
represented, again,
a spectrum of the cancer
community and included clinicians,
researchers, advocates, Ellen
was among them, representatives
from Pharma, from the IT
community, from the private sector,
and the panel itself had
three face-to-face meetings
to identify the areas
that we would focus
on to consider the recommendations
and then to finalize what would be
in the report that would be sent
to the task force and
the vice president.
In order to accomplish that, seven
working groups were organized.
Each of the working groups
was co-chaired by two members
of the Blue Ribbon Panel,
so we had good continuity
between the panel itself
and the working groups.
And those areas of investigation
were clinical trails, data sharing,
cancer immunology, tumor
evolution, implementation science,
pediatric cancer, precession
prevention, and early detection.
So the entire span of
cancer with the goal
of identifying those research
opportunities and each
of those areas that were
poised to be accelerated.
Because as Ellen pointed out, the
goal here is to try to accomplish
in 5 years what would
normally take 10.
So to really specifically
find to that segment
of the entire cancer research
portfolio, that could be accelerated
with the additional funds
that would be coming
for research through the Cures Act.
The working groups met weekly--
each of the groups met every week
to discuss-- first, to identify
those areas within their topic
and then to really discuss
which ones were the best poise
to be accelerated and then
to finally generate two
to three recommendations
for consideration
by the Blue Ribbon Panel.
In addition, because all there
are 28 people and 7 working groups
with a total of about a 150
people involved sounds like a lot,
it's really only a fraction
of the whole cancer community.
So we wanted to also have
outreach activities to let anyone
who had an idea submitted.
And so we had a variety of ways in
which people could submit ideas.
The major one was a website
where people could go
and submit their ideas.
We also had so-called listening
sessions at some large conferences.
And in the end we had over
1,600 ideas that were submitted.
Each one of them was
actually read and considered,
and in a gratifying way all of the
ideas that we received were ones
that had been touched upon
by one of the working groups.
So we felt pretty confident
that we had covered everything
that could be covered.
So, in the end, we had a
total of 13 recommendations.
They were summarized in the
report in 10 recommendations.
There was some overlap
in the recommendations.
And those recommendations identify
exceptional research opportunities
that are poised to be accelerated
and could powerfully advance
our understanding of cancer.
And you can read the report in
its entirety at that website.
I've also noted the website at the
bottom of every slide if you want
to jot it down and take a
look at the report later.
I could have the next slide.
There were a number of cross-cutting
themes that were identified
that coursed through all
of the recommendations,
prominent among them was
health disparities research.
There was also a clear interest
in developing a national network
of patient biological
and clinical data,
so that we could amass more
data about each of the cancers
to really learn more
about it in depth.
Prevention, development of
biomarkers and new technologies,
was cited in many of the
recommendations as with data sharing
and the need to develop
computational models.
And finally and importantly,
the need to collaborate
across all the sectors was
highlighted as essential
for really advancing
our understanding.
In the next few slides, I'm
going to very briefly touch
on the 10 recommendations that
are summarized in the report just
so you have a sense of the
flavor of each of them.
I'll note that the
recommendations are listed
in alphabetical order, if you will.
We didn't want to assign
numbers to them
to give any implication
of prioritization.
The way that recommendations
were developed,
they're all high priority
and of equal priority.
So, A, is the network for
direct patient engagement.
The idea is to allow any patient
anywhere to be able to engage
with the research community
through a network,
and that they could then
pre-register for any clinical trials
that might become available.
Cancer immunotherapy,
translational science network,
I think we've all heard about the
huge promise of cancer immunotherapy
but we have a lot to learn.
And so this network is designed to
give us insights into such things
as why do many patients
quickly develop resistance
or not respond at all.
Leading to the next topic which
is to identify the mechanisms
of therapeutic resistance so that we
can predict who is going to respond
and who is going to be resistant.
Creation of a national cancer data
ecosystem, as I think you've heard
from Vice President Biden, data
sharing is of utmost importance
and the goal here is really to link
everybody and all the data sets.
And importantly, allow patient
access to those data as well.
So the patients will be an important
component of that ecosystem.
A huge emphasis on pediatric
cancer, which is very different
from adult cancer, so a focus
on the specific kinds of tumors
and abnormal proteins that are
generated in pediatric cancer.
And I think Ms. Lyle referred to
this a real interest in trying
to understand the symptoms that
develop as a result of the therapy
and how do we manage them
and how do we support them.
And finally, precision,
prevention, and early detection,
obviously if we can prevent cancer,
we're much better off than having
to treat it and therefore
we need to also be able
to detect it very early on.
The last three, we can learn
from patients who've
already been treated.
We can try to really probe
in depth the biospecimens
that we've collected to begin
to understand who responds
to therapy and who doesn't.
I alluded to that in
terms of immunotherapy
but we can do it much more
broadly for all types of therapy.
Finally, creation of a tumor atlas.
To understand in depth
the molecular and cellular
and architectural components of
a tumor from the earliest stages
through to a frank tumor, through
their resistance to metastasis,
so that at each stage we might
be able to predict how it's going
to proceed and how it
will respond to therapy.
And finally, again, importantly
in almost everything we do,
the development of new
enabling technologies.
So what are the next steps now
that the Cures Act is passed?
The reports both from the Blue
Ribbon Panel and the Task Force,
the overarching body,
were released in October.
And I'll give you a
very quick summary
of the Task Force report
in a minute.
We're beginning to
implement the recommendations.
We're starting to launch those that
are feasible to do this fiscal year,
and then for succeeding fiscal years
we'll look to our advisory boards
and outside advisors
to really identify how
to best proceed with
the implementation.
Of course we're going to establish
public-private partnerships,
to help us with this, what we've
outlined exceeds what anybody could
give us and so we need to
partner with other agencies
and with the private sector.
And philosophically, it's something
we feel as important to do to engage
as much of the community as we can.
And I should point out, and I know
Dr. Lowy will probably also want
to point this out, that even
though we're putting huge emphasis
on this segment of our
research portfolio,
all the other research needs
to continue to be supported,
young investigators need to be
supported, and so we are going
to be conscientious in paying
attention to those components
of cancer research
that are not identified
in the Blue Ribbon report.
Quickly, the Task Force identified
a number of strategic goals
in its report catalyzing new
scientific breakthroughs.
Their focus was on the technology
expanding mobile devices, et cetera.
Data sharing, bringing
new therapies to patients
in this case really focusing
much more on clinical trials
and eligibility then was cited
in the Blue Ribbon Panel report.
Strengthening prevention
and diagnosis
and importantly improving
patient access and care.
So I think between
the Task Force report
and the Blue Ribbon Panel report,
we've really covered the entire
spectrum of cancer research
and treatment and patient
engagement.
And I'll end simply by
thanking Ms. Lyle for giving us
such a moving account of
her journey through cancer.
And everything we're doing
through the Moonshot is really
benefit patients like Ms. Lyle,
her sister, and everybody else who's
been touched by cancer and to try
to prevent others from
going through that.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Douglas Lowy: Good afternoon.
I'm Doug Lowy.
I'm the Acting Director of
the National Cancer Institute.
And I first want to say that it
really is extraordinary for us
to be here in the Library
of Congress, because I think
of the Library of Congress as
the place that is the storehouse
of accumulated knowledge for not
just the United States but also
for the world and its
continued accumulation.
And what I think that
we're going to--
what we're talking about is what--
where we have been and where
we are and where we hope to go.
It's extraordinary for those of
us in cancer research to see how
in many ways we are favored.
And in terms of the president
of the United States, last year,
having a precision medicine
initiative in oncology, this year,
the Cancer Moonshot, and really
the overall goals are paradoxically
simultaneously so that there will
be more Juanita Lyles because people
who get cancer, more
of them will do better.
But on the other hand, there
will be fewer Juanita Lyles
because there'll be fewer
people getting cancer.
And that really is
what this is about.
I have, I think, a
total of eight slides.
The first four are really
kind of trying to set
for you some understanding and
rationale of why cancer, why now.
And the first slide shows what
has happened to mortality rates
since the mid '90s for cancer.
And this is cancer in general.
Men are in blue on top because they
have the highest mortality rates,
women are in black on the bottom,
and both genders together
are in red.
And what I would like you to see
is, number one, mortality rate
in general, going down, and if
you compare the rate of decrease
of the most recent 10-year
period for which we have data,
it is going to down faster
than the rate of decrease
for the next earlier 10 years.
Next slide, please.
What this slide depicts for
you is that it is most cancers.
It's not just people are smoking
less and so we have less one cancer,
and that accounts for the major
change in mortality rates.
It is important.
But what's shown here is in the
blue, the decreased percentage
of mortality over the last 10
years for which we have data.
And you can see on the left
is men, on the right is women.
And in red are those cancers whose
mortality rates are going up.
And so we need to pay
a special attention
to those that are going up.
But before I talk briefly
about one of them,
note that this is attributable
to decreases in the majority
of the most common cancers.
And that this decrease we think will
continue and we want it if anything
to accelerate as a result
of the Cancer Moonshot.
So, let me call your attention
to the one that is increasing
for liver cancer both
for men and for women.
A large problem of this is
an increase in the incidence
and prevalence of hepatitis C virus
infection, which is actually related
to opioid epidemic and
other kinds of drug use.
As Dr. Sigal pointed out, the
opioid epidemic is front and center
with the 21st Century Cures.
But mortality rates from
hepatitis C virus infection
in the United States are
now almost twice as high
as mortality rates
from HIV infection.
And the prediction is that
over the next 15 years
that the mortality rates will more
than double and come close to triple
from this infection
in the United States.
And so, one of the things that we're
going to try to do is to intervene
to reduce mortality rates before
people develop liver cancer,
before they develop cirrhosis,
before they develop liver failure.
Next slide.
You may have seen this
front page article last week
from Lenny Bernstein who's talking
about life expectancy declining
for the first time since 1993.
And these are from the
most recent data from 2015,
the data that I have shown
you or the detailed analysis
that we have done through 2014.
And 8 of the most common--
of the 10 most common causes,
the mortality rates went up, the
ninth was essentially stable.
But the 10th, what I've
highlighted in blue,
is that the report's lone
bright spot was a drop
in death rate from cancer.
So, the death rates from
cancer have continued even
with the most recent data, and
despite other common causes
of death having increased.
Next slide.
So, I think this-- I see this as
a kind of a lead in "why now?"
for the Cancer Moonshot.
The need has been present for
decades but it's now matched
by the opportunity
to be able to benefit
from a major infusion
of additional resources.
And you heard from Ellen
and also from Dinah
about these opportunities.
In some-- I mean, obviously, many--
too many people die from cancer.
About one and a half
million get cancer,
about 600,000 died
from cancer each year.
But as you can see from the
decreasing mortality rates,
we are doing better.
And it's at a time when you're
doing better and it's not just
for one disease, it's not just
prevention, not just screening,
not just treatment but it's
a combination of those.
That's the time when an increase
in investment is most likely
to yield results that are
beneficial for patient's prevention,
screening, and treatment.
Another reason is that
immunotherapy has come of age.
And I think that we've all been
really impressed to see people
such as President Carter who had
metastatic melanoma to his brain
and was able to go about his
business and get a check--
an immune checkpoint inhibitor
and he is now cancer-free
and building houses for
Habitat for Humanity just
like any 91-year-old
person would be doing.
[ Laughter ]
So the next slide basically depicts
for you diagrammatically how
we view the Moonshot itself.
Where in purple, there
is a lot of research.
We've come to this point as a result
of research that has been conducted.
But the Blue Ribbon Panel
really looked at issues,
what's poised for acceleration,
and that's shown in the blue part.
Next slide.
And Dinah has already gone over
some of them but I just want
to highlight two of them for you.
The so-called tumor cell atlas.
We had a signature program over
the last 10 years called the Cancer
Genome Atlas that was funded
both by the NCI as well
as by the Genome Research Institute.
And there are three important ways
where technological developments
over the last decade means
that we can learn even more
about the details of how cancer
comes about than we could from TCGA.
And we think that this will--
this understanding will help us in
prevention screening and treatment.
So, we're going to try to look at
the three-dimensional organization
of what's called the
micro environment.
That is not just the tumor but also
the cells that surround the tumor;
the cells of the immune
system, for example.
The technology also now enables us
to do detailed analysis
of very small lesions.
That was not possible 10 years ago.
So we can look premalignant
lesions in ways
that have never been
examined before.
And by looking sequentially over
time, we can look at the progression
and evolution of the tumor from
its earliest point to most advance.
Dinah mentioned pediatric
cancer, and I'm just going
to mention one aspect which
is fusion oncoproteins.
And those are proteins that are
rearranged that don't occur normally
but occur in a fairly large
number of children with cancer,
but they're different
rearranged proteins
for different kinds of cancers.
This is a difficult
thing to do but--
and there is not much
financial incentive
for the pharmaceutical industry,
biotech, to do it but we are--
we already have announced an
effort to ask our investigators
to make proposals for
how to make such--
to make inhibitors against
such fusion oncoproteins,
because we think that
in many instances,
they actually are important
drivers of the cancers in children.
Immunotherapy is really front and
center among the recommendations.
But Dr. Weiner is going to-- this is
his area of research and he is going
to talk a bit about what's happening
and what the opportunities
are in immunotherapy.
And I would point out
that in addition
to our being extraordinarily
fortunate to have Ellen
on the Blue Ribbon Panel,
because having patient advocates
on the panel make sure that
the recommendations were going
to be patient-centric.
But in addition, we had people
from the pharmaceutical industry,
people from academia
who do immunotherapy
and make recommendations for
us so that we're not competing
with the pharmaceutical
industry, we're not competing
with private philanthropy
trying to develop immunotherapy,
but instead are doing
supporting activities
that complement what they do or
are distinct from what they do.
Next slide.
The last part is really
especially for Dr. Charles,
because prevention really
is front and center.
And as Dinah mentioned, cancer
health disparities which we view
as racial, socio-economic,
and demographic,
and many of the proposals of-- in
the implementation part are designed
to decrease the incidents
of cancer or to have people
who get cancer have
a better outcome.
And because of time,
I'm just going to focus
on colorectal cancer screening.
Why colorectal cancer screening?
Two reasons, need and opportunity.
The need is that this is one of
the most common causes of death
from cancer in the United States,
about 50,000 people die
of colorectal cancer.
What's the opportunity?
We've improved treatment to a
great degree but we also know
that colorectal cancer screening
actually can decrease the incidents
of this cancer and
decrease mortality.
The problem is that it is an
underutilized effort for screening.
There's a lot more publicity, for
example, for breast cancer screening
but the opportunities to
save lives in the short-term
from increased uptake
of high quality colorectal cancer
screening are simply extraordinary.
So, I will stop there and I
really appreciate the opportunity
of talking with you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Charles: Thank
you Dr. Singer and Lowy.
I think by now everyone is
getting a really clear picture
of why we are having this panel
and how much promise there is
in the future both for us and
for the community at large.
And I think this is just wonderful.
Are we loading-- You're done.
Dr. Weiner's slides.
[ Laughter ]
We have loaded Dr. Weiner slides.
And I'm sure he was happy to hear
Dr. Lowy say, immunotherapy has come
of age, because that is
his area of expertise
that is focused there at Georgetown.
And again, Dr. Weiner
has been an integral part
of this panel and effort.
He is the Director of Georgetown's
Lombardi Comprehensive Cancer Center
and holds many distinctions
of Francis
and Charlotte Gragnani Chair,
a professor of oncology
at Georgetown University
Medical Center, and responsible
for the operation development
of the cancer center,
including the research, clinical,
and educational missions.
And I think over my time here
starting medical school in the '70s
until now, I have watched the center
grow and expand and come of age
in itself and become a very integral
part of the cancer community.
So, it's a pleasure
to welcome Dr. Weiner.
And would you please come.
>> Douglas Lowy: While Dr.
Weiner is coming to the podium,
I want to point out that he
is the Chair of our Board
of Scientific Counselors in the
Intramural Research Program.
And we benefit enormously
from his advising council.
>> Louis Weiner: Thank you for that.
I'm here with some of my heroes
and with another one of my heroes
because we do all this for you.
And I think it's really
important to always make sure
that we keep the patient at
the center of everything we do.
So, as the Director of a
Comprehensive Cancer Center,
there are 47 cancer
centers like ours scattered
around the United States.
We have a great opportunity
to work together.
And I think it's important to note
that while the Moonshot has
created a roadmap, an infrastructure
that helps us I think to really
sharpen our focus on areas
of great opportunity, it's
also true that it's not
like we haven't been
communicating all along.
I mean, we do an awful lot of
work together where, you know,
the enemy is cancer; it's not
the other cancer center, right?
And so, what we're trying to do and
I think do very well is communicate,
interact with each other
at the cancer center level
around the United States.
And in fact, as Dr. Lowy just
mentioned, working with the Board
of Scientific Counselors of
National Cancer Institute is a group
of external scientists
and physicians who come
and advised Dr. Lowy on the
quality of research being done
on the NCI campus, NIH, and up at
the Frederick campus in Frederick.
And so, we have a great opportunity,
I think, for collaboration
and to really make sure
we're keeping our game sharp
and we keep it sharp in the
interest of our patients.
So, I had the pleasure
of being a member
of the Immunotherapy Task
Force and I've been interested
in cancer immunotherapy
for a long time.
Stated simply, immunotherapy is
treating the patient's immune system
so that their immune
system can treat the cancer.
It's a very different thing than
treating with a drug that's designed
to kill the cancer or
giving a radiation particle
or even a surgical procedure.
This is basically giving
people the tools they need
to get rid of their own cancer.
And it's really a radical
concept and it's something
that I think we're still learning
how to grapple with and how
to understand in order
to make it work better.
Now, when I got starter in thinking
about immunotherapy some 30 years
ago, I got to tell you people
who were looking out for
me thought I was crazy
because they actually thought
that just didn't make any sense.
The immune system has
no relevance in cancer.
But they were wrong.
And so, this a slide-- this is
the only real data slide I'm going
to show you so don't get too
concerned, which is related
to a disease that Dr. Lowy was
talking about, colon cancer.
Because even though
this is a disease
that can almost completely be
prevented by regular screening
and having-- so that nobody need
necessarily die from it just about.
The fact is that it's still one of
the most common causes of cancer
and cancer death in
the United States
because people don't get
their screening done.
So, even a relatively early stage
like stage two colon cancer
can be cured quite commonly
but only 80% of the time.
Twenty percent of the people
are dealing with the relapse.
And using the conventional
staging that we had developed
over the years, we knew that if you
had a so-called stage two cancer
and you gave somebody chemotherapy
after they recovered from surgery,
they had about an 80% chance of
being cured, then we go up to 83%
if you give the chemotherapy.
So, what that meant is you
would have to treat 100 people
with toxic chemotherapy in order
to potentially save three people.
Eighty of them had
made no difference.
They were going to be cured
anyway so you wasted their time.
And for 17 of them, it didn't matter
because it wasn't going to work.
So, the question is, how do
we actually do a better job?
And the first way you can do
a better job is by figuring
out who the 17 were going to
or the 20 were going to be.
And it turns out by analyzing the
way the body's immune system was
reacting against the
cancer, you got a better idea
of what was going to happen.
And moreover, it became clear
that the immune system was
controlling cancer outcomes.
Next slide.
So, you heard about
the war against cancer.
This is President Nixon declaring
the War on Cancer in 1971
and signing the National Cancer Act.
Next. But we have been at war
against cancer throughout
human history.
This is a photograph of exhumation
of a grave of a Medieval Saxon man
and you can he has a large
tumor on his left leg, OK?
So, we've been fighting this
throughout human history.
And in fact, next slide, the
war on cancer is actually not
between oncologists and cancer.
It's not between pharmaceutical
companies and the FDA.
The war on cancer is for
one person at a time.
And the primary combatants are
the malignant cell population
and the host immune system.
Every single cancer that
develops in a person's bodies,
that is so-called successful, has
figured out a way to either defeat
or deflect the body's immune system
that was directed against it.
And this is a concept that I
believe was long time and coming.
So, how does that happen?
Firstly, a cancer can overwhelm the
immune system by just racing faster.
That does not happen very often.
Sometimes it can hide.
It can actually stay
away from the recognition
and then you will have
a big problem.
But there are now treatments
that are being developed
that can actually overcome
that by artificially--
by figuring out what might be
attacked artificial using something
called CAR T-cells.
You can subvert-- The cancer
can subvert the body--
body's response by elaborating
chemicals that might block signals.
And you can actually attack
that with drugs and antibodies.
And the cancers can shield
themselves to exclude the T-cells
of the body's immune system
from attacking the cancer.
And finally, when all
else is failed,
a cancer can deactivate
tumor-targeting T-cells
that attack tumor cells.
And this is using a strategy
called checkpoint inhibition.
Next. How does this happen?
Well, what-- if you think about
it, it's a fantastic system.
What happens is that as a
T-cell that's loaded and ready
to kill the cancer cell that
it recognizes it being--
as being foreign, gets into
the neighborhood of the cancer,
the cancer basically erects
checkpoints that will protect it.
And on the next slide, you can
see that it may be using cannon
at the gate of the castle,
maybe it's a checkpoint,
but perhaps it's really this,
it's really Snow White
eating the poison apple.
And the poison apple is basically
the tumor that is putting the T-cell
of the body's immune
system to sleep, OK?
And you can reverse that
process with antibodies
that are proteins made by the--
that you can craft in the laboratory
that are ordinarily in
our bodies, of course,
that can actually block the
ability of the killer cells
of the immune system to be put
to sleep by the tumor cells.
And so, this is a really
complicated slide.
There's only one thing
that matters here.
As a T-cell of the body's
immune system is coming
in to attack a cancer,
what happens is
that the tumor cell will elaborate
various molecules that protect it
and they will put it to sleep.
And one of the most powerful tools
of this is a molecule called PD-L1
which is a great defense mechanism.
And antibodies against PD-L1
or against the T-cell marker
called PD-1 have been able
to essentially have remarkably
anti-tumor activities.
Next slide.
This is one example.
This is a disease called malignant
melanoma, where individuals
who are near endstage
of their cancer with it
with survival expectancies of
six or seven months and had been
through many other
treatments that had not--
had no longer work for them
or had never worked at all,
they were treated with a combination
of checkpoint antibodies.
And it was expected that
they would live seven months.
Their average survival is quite
a bit longer than 40 months now.
Many of these people
are being but looks
like may be even cured
by this treatment.
And as you can see in these
two plots here, on the top,
this is looking at each line
represents an individual patient.
And you can see the
vast majority of people
who were treated in
this clinical trial.
The volume of the tumor
which is on the Y-axis
of this particular chart
drops and it's sustained
and it doesn't grow back.
And if you look at the magnitude
of the response that you see
on the bottom plot, you can
see that the vast majority,
these people have fantastic
anti-tumor responses.
This is a change.
This is something we
had never seen before.
This is a pictorial depiction,
if you will, of the revolution
that we're experiencing
in cancer care.
Next slide.
And this is just the
tip of the iceberg.
Well, there are-- I'd last counted--
So we have a game at
Georgetown where we try
and count how many different tumors
are now potentially responsive
to checkpoint antibodies, and we're
up to 23 different cancers now.
Now, here's the new--
And that's great news.
But I want you to understand
and I think Dr. Singer mentioned
it before, the great news is
that these are treatments that can
work in lot of different cancers
but it's the rarer type of cancer
where these treatments work
all the time in every patient.
Let's have a significant minority
of patients, sometimes as many
as 30 will respond to a single--
at this checkpoint antibodies.
In one case, Hodgkin's disease,
maybe as many as 80% will respond
with a favorable outcome.
But on ballots, it's
usually about 20%.
And figuring out who those
20% are so we can treat them
and understanding what the-- what's
happening with the other 80%,
why don't-- why do their cancers
relapse, why don't they respond
in the first place, what other
mechanisms are they using is one
of the great challenges.
And that's where the
Moonshot comes in.
Because the immunotherapy
focus of the Moonshot is
to create a clinical infrastructure,
if you will, that will allow us
to do the kinds of high
quality clinical trials
so we can deeply interrogate
these issues in collaboration
so that we can identify
who should be treated,
when they should be treated, and
how their cancers are responding
or not responding to the
treatments that we're using.
And the other point that I think
Dr. Lowy mentioned was the idea
of using the sort of a tumor
cell atlas to not only think
about what's going on in the cancer
cells that are in the cancer mass
but what's happening with the
immune component of the tumor,
we need to understand how that woks.
So these are absolutely
foundational and really,
really important new strategies
that are being employed,
that are going be facilitated by the
Moonshot and really will allow us
to accelerate our progress
in a very meaningful way.
Next slide.
So, I'm not going to read that but
it except to say that I do think
that cancer immunology
is a next great frontier.
I think anybody who spends as
much time as I do at NCI is awed
by the remarkable depth
and diversity
of extraordinary research
being done.
And there are lots and lots of
wonderful initiatives going on.
But there can be no doubt that
immunology is one of them.
And I think it's really
critically important to know
that the Moonshot is going
to make these things happen
and happen more quickly because
people's lives depend on it.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Charles: Well, thank you
Dr. Weiner and other panelists.
And while you frame your questions,
which I'm sure there are several.
And here's one lady, I'll let her
ask her question before I give one.
Go ahead please.
One moment, we'll bring you a
microphone so everyone can hear
and we'll capture it
on the recording.
Yeah, get your voice together.
[ Laughter ]
>> Iris Portney: Thank you.
And thank you for all your work
and this is always so exciting.
I would like to say-- Well, my name
Iris Portney [assumed spelling]
and I'm so in awe of our first
speaker about her journey.
I will tell you that even though
much of my life was related
on science and technology-based
policy,
I happened to be an 18-year survivor
of inflammatory breast cancer.
So, in terms of-- yes,
nodding go up there.
So, as part of that
experience, you know,
I went through stem
cell transplants,
any variety of sequential
treatments.
And at the beginning, my
focus was, as with your report
and recommendations, first--
your first focus is prevention,
which should haven't happened.
Second focus is treatment and
outcomes, hoping you find the stuff
that works, obviously
we found various things.
But the third focus and I know
as the saying goes
high quality problem,
the third focus is survivorship,
potential toxicity of treatments,
so that you can anticipate,
recognize them right away,
factor that into informed
consent and choices
about what to combine and when.
And so, the patient doesn't feel
kind of crazy bouncing from doctor
to doctor with the symptom,
et cetera, et cetera.
So in that context-- Oh, I have
lots of large print notes to myself.
Don't get scared, but I discovered
five years after I had had F5U,
God bless it, responded well.
But only five years later was
a clinical trial research study
released that said that it
actually produced a certain amount
of brain damage aftereffect.
Wish I'd known that, we were covered
now, but still need more talk input.
So, I just want to suggest
this as a missing focus.
I'm sure at some place
in the long report,
I haven't read the entire thing,
but it certainly wasn't a
working group focus and it wasn't
in the executive summary.
And that is research focus on
creating an extensive data base,
clinical-based data on
survivorship complications.
I'm very struck by the-- for
instance, the establishment
and work being done by ASCO
on their cancer link database,
because as you all know, 3%
of patients give data on,
you know, on clinical trials.
But what I was up against in our
real time stuff was reporting
to wonderful doctors, who are
also professors and researchers,
things that seemed unrelated,
and in the end they would say,
all I can say is we didn't
think it was connected
because we'd never seen it.
And I said, "Great, this
is all state of the art,
who are you reporting this to?"
And their answer would be,
"No place to report it."
So I said, "How do we know
with these new treatments--
because we were using them
as soon as they came out--
that there aren't other patients
that are getting them in other part
of the country, talking it
to their doctors reporting it
so that data can be looked at and
assessed in some sort of patterns.
>> Sandra Charles: So let's--
>> Iris Portney: So I would hope you
get like a 10 to 20-year database
that could be collected for stuff
so that researchers and doctors
and patients can begin
to identify patterns
that they weren't even looking
for as the need comes up.
>> Sandra Charles: Thank you.
I think that's a very well
succinct way of saying this.
And maybe we have one
of our panelists
who would like to address that.
>> Louis Weiner: Well, why don't
you start and I can add it to that.
>> Douglas Lowy: Yeah.
So, one of the recommendations
is patient-reported outcomes
and that real-- and
survivorship, if you will,
that's a part and parcel of it.
And so, it actually is specifically
called out in the recommendations.
In addition, we have,
for many years,
supported children's
cohort survivorship study,
where we look at least
two different issues.
One is the outcomes
and the other is--
and for example, there are increased
risks of second cancers aside
from long and short-- other
long and short-term side effects
but also looking over time to try
to make sure that the incidence
of serious side effects
is actually going down.
We are in discussion of
developing an adult cohort
that would be looking
specifically at that issue.
>> Yeah.
>> Sandra Charles: And
this young lady back here.
>> Go ahead.
You go and then I'll go.
>> Louis Weiner: Yeah, yeah.
>> Sandra Charles: And Dr.
Weiner wanted to address it also.
>> Louis Weiner: So, you raised
an incredibly important point.
And I think it's a point that we
are coming to perhaps a little later
than we would have
liked to in the field,
partly because we haven't
had the luxury of having
as many people being cured
as we're beginning to have--
nor we had the great benefit of--
with almost as great benefit of
people who are maybe not cured
but having the diseases controlled
for very long periods of time
so that they-- you know, we
have to think about things.
And it's very interesting,
because I think health systems
around the country are
beginning to understand this
as being an important need
for the patient population
and we're beginning to test out
different strategies, you know,
should this be oncology based,
should it be internal medicine
or family practice based,
there's a lot of question
that need to be addressed.
The other thing that's happening,
though, is that as the kinds
of treatment we give
our patients change,
we are finding different patterns of
long-term side effects of, you know,
there are anybody who experienced
chemotherapy back in the old days,
you know, was, you know what the
side effects were going to be,
you know what the long-term
consequences would be.
And we, as doctors, we're very good
at treating very specific
sides effects associated
with high-dose chemotherapy,
for example.
Now, with these immunotherapy
strategies, for example,
we have to become doctors in
a different way all over again
because now we have people whose
body's immune systems have been
activated or causing all kinds
of new and different kinds
of long-term consequences
that we have to understand.
We all recognize that
these consequences are
in some ways good,
paradoxically good.
It's because they're working
and people are living longer
and more people are
potentially being cured
and that's a wonderful thing.
But we're finding out that some
of these treatments
can attack the heart
in ways we never even dreamt before.
And we all have to become sensitized
and, you know, sharpen our readings
so that we can understand
what has to be done,
and sharing that information
so that we can all learn
about it is absolutely essential.
>> Sandra Charles: Dr. Sigal.
>> Ellen Sigal: Yeah.
I just want to take this one also.
It's an incredibly important point.
Thirty years ago, we knew there was
toxicity but we were really fighting
for life, and honestly
just tolerated a lot
and we didn't have a lot
of long-term [inaudible].
We actually have a lot of data now,
but there is a huge problem with it.
First of all, it exists in much
different database-- basis.
They don't talk to one another.
They're not linked, so the
FDA has the sentinel project
which is safety data, which
is really claims data,
but they have almost
200 million lives on it.
So they have a lot of information.
I was at PCORI.
I'm on the board of the
patient-centered research outcomes
and we have probably 70 to
100 millions lives in it.
And we have the cancer
link and then we have the--
insurance companies
have a lot of data.
The problem is, is they're not
synchronized, they don't talk
to one another, they're
in different formats,
electronic health records
and a claims data.
So, linking them to
understand is important.
But there is a new emphasis.
Also, the NCI has [inaudible] so
this is really the idea of quality
of life data, really defining
metrics that are uniform
so we can really understand
it before that companies
where people would say,
well, you feel better,
there were less hospitalization
but the data wasn't rigorous,
we didn't understand the standards.
And FDA took the lead-- I'm sorry,
NCI took the lead on it [inaudible].
And now this really means that when
companies are already doing their
trials or when we are
doing our trials,
even at the National
Cancer Institute,
we can incorporate these bonafide
data sets and really understand.
And what we're trying to do
at France is work with the FDA
to have these as label indications.
So if you really have a treatment or
choices between multiple treatments
and you have a label
indication that one is less toxic
or has different side effects and
they're both as equally efficacious,
you can make more informed
decisions.
So this is becoming very
important but there--
it's highly complex because there
are different forms of cancer,
different types of
treatments, we didn't know them.
But putting this data together
and getting out of our silos
and harmonizing it, it is going
to become incredibly important.
>> Sandra Charles: Thank you.
Back here.
>> Maureen Harrington:
Hi, thank you.
I'm Maureen Harrington.
I'm assistant general counsel here.
And, first of all,
thanks to Dr. Charles
for putting together this
terrific panel and thank to--
thanks to you all for being here
and for the very important
work that you're doing.
I'm wondering if you are going to
be examining at all the role of diet
and cancer prevention treatment.
I know the World Health Organization
recently found that meat
and processed meats in particular,
were a contributing factor.
And I haven't gone through all of
your report yet, but what I did see,
I didn't really see that addressed.
Is that something you'll
be exploring?
>> Douglas Lowy: The short answer
is we are supporting research
in this area.
I want to emphasize something
that Dr. Singer said.
This is a subset of the
research activities of the NCI.
Given the status of diet and
nutrition and our understanding
of it, it's an area where
there's enormous need.
Whether there is the same
opportunity right now,
I think is not entirely resolved.
So this is an area where we need
to continue to support research
but it's not directly part of the
Blue Ribbon Panel recommendations.
>> Sandra Charles: Dr. Singer?
>> Dinah Singer: Yeah.
Just to build on what Dr. Lowy said.
In the working groups, a
variety of things were discussed
as potential for acceleration.
In the early detection and
prevention working group
and actually in the implementation
science working group, both,
the conversations included the
question of diet and behavior
and could anything be done there.
And as Doug mentioned, the
sense was we have a lot
of research really going on
especially in the division
of cancer prevention but nothing
that could be clearly specified
as poised for acceleration.
And so, the conclusion was
to allow NCI to continue
to support our ongoing portfolio,
continue to pay attention to it
but not highlighted as one
of the recommendations.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
It's ongoing research that
we'll continue to support.
>> Ellen Sigal: I just
want to add to that.
First of all, we know a lot now.
There's a lot-- I mean,
first of all,
not only at the National Cancer
Institute which has a budget
of over 5 billion but there are
other institutes [inaudible] this
and American Cancer Society.
But, you know, we know
a lot about tobacco.
We know a lot about obesity.
We know a lot about
things that are screening.
And unfortunately, there are--
you know, we still struggle
with behavioral changes.
I mean, that's really obesity
is becoming a huge issue.
So there's a lot that we have to
study and we have to understand,
not only the science
but the behavior.
I mean, I'm still astounded
about how many people walk
and walk around, and
not just in Europe,
which is decreasing
a bit but even here.
Our rates have come down a lot.
Screening there's a lot
going on, on lung cancer.
So, it is a very important
component.
But there's tremendous amount that
we know now that's not being done.
>> Sandra Charles: Somebody
in the back here first,
and then here and here.
>> Yeah. How you doing?
I'm a cancer survivor-- prostate.
I have-- The only problem I have,
I have side effects
from too much radiation.
At times I get-- the blood clots
be coming and pain is terrible.
I have to flush my system
a lot by drinking water.
OK. Are you all working
on, you know,
when you get too much radiation of--
>> Louis Weiner: Yeah.
Those are very significant problems.
And this is another
survivorship question.
>> Sandra Charles: Yes.
>> Sandra Charles: Louis Weiner:
It's really all about that.
And, you know, it's obviously hard
to comment on any individual case.
But what I can say is that your
story reminds us how important it is
to remember that when
we cure somebody,
we have to make sure we
cure them in such a way
that they can live well for--
in addition to living longer.
And this is where innovation
and technology and--
can really play a role.
So, at Lombardi, we are
finishing the installation
of a proton therapy radiation unit.
And, you know, there
are some evidence
and certainly there has been
good evidence over the years
that as radiation therapy
machines have improved
in their technological
sophistication,
you can give a tighter and
tighter degree of radiation right
around the tumor and you can
spare with the normal tissue
so you don't have some of
those terrible side effects
that you just described.
So, I actually think that
in part, the way we're going
to be addressing a lot of
these long-term side effects is
by developing better
targeted treatments be
at medicines or radiation
or surgery.
And I think the-- And the other
thing we have to do, though,
is we have to remember-- and this is
where survivorship research
can make a difference,
it's care research as well.
How do we best find ways
to help people who suffer
from these kinds of side effects?
And so, I think-- again, it's--
we're still in the earliest phases
of this to some degree
and it's a shame
that we haven't made more
progress in many ways.
But I think that over
the next few years,
we're going to see an increasing
focus on helping people clean
up the mess that the
doctors made after we got--
recovered with their cancer.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Sandra Charles.
Oh, here, Stephanie.
Here comes the mic.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
I don't need a mic.
Hi, I'm Stephanie Marcus
from here at the library
and I'm a science librarian.
As we were talking,
I was thinking back
on my own family's experience back
in 1977 when my dad was diagnosed
with prostate cancer,
which was missed
by the local physician
in a town of 2,500.
And luckily, not in the end,
but I was here at the library
and had resources like I
did research even though
in those days we didn't
have much for databases
but I could find articles
and I found
that there were the
NCI cancer centers
and I contacted [inaudible]
someone in Rosewell in Buffalo
and they directed us to Iowa City
where my dad got some treatment.
In the end he died, but I'm thinking
now of all the people who go
to their local doctors who
don't really know that much
and how can we be assured that
they're going to find us the care
that we need, they're
not going to miss things
and they're going to
have the resources.
Because it still happens.
You hear about people who do their
own research, patients and parents
who go out and movies are made
about it, but is there going
to be something done about making
sure everyone can get the care
they need?
>> Ellen Sigal: I can
start to take that on.
It's very complicated.
One of the things that came
up on the National Cancer Act
is this extraordinary resource
of these cancer centers
all through the country.
So, there are-- How
many comprehensive?
>> Louis Weiner: There's
47 comprehensives.
>> Ellen Sigal: Forty-seven and?
>> Louis Weiner: And there's
about 68, I think it is.
About 69?
>> Ellen Sigal: Sixty-nine.
So, the thing about it is, these
are highly trained academics doing
research and clinical care.
Eighty-five percent of our patients
get treated in a community setting.
And in some cases, in
most cases, it's fine.
However, there is a huge
variance in standards of care
in how people are treated.
And I always encourage people
to go for a second opinion.
You know, we have this-- these
centers all over the country.
And although there is terrific
community care in most cases,
and in most cases they're
frankly doing a good job
but people get very scared when
they get a diagnosis of cancer
and they want to immediately
get treatment.
And sometimes, going to experts who
have specific expertise in that form
of cancer at one of our centers,
is really very, very, very helpful.
And there are standards and
there are guidelines and there's,
of course, research that you can do.
But it's complex and it is uneven
and of course in minority areas
and where there are
really, you know,
not the resources rural populations,
it's really very troubling
and very difficult to get
patients to the right care.
But if they can get to a center or
if they can get a second opinion,
it really can be as really
life-- it can change your life.
>> Sandra Charles: Let me say on
that note that the partnerships
that are mentioned in your report--
in your recommendation of
having public, private,
as well as other partnerships,
is where we at the library,
in the health unit, and other parts,
can play a role because that is one
of the things that will help bring
forums such as this out in the open
where people come in and ask
questions here about resources,
plus we will have on
hand within our office,
on our website resources
to share with people.
So as we continue this and
have these partnerships,
I can see as really playing our
role in getting the word out
and getting people
particularly the ones
who are the non-scientific patient
community, knowing what is going on
and take-- and we're also the ones
who answer the questions of quality
of life and care resources
when people experience some
other side effects that they do.
So, already, I see a lot of
different reasons for you to return
and have a new visitor experience.
One second, Mr. Simon
here has a question.
Actually I see many other questions.
I'm pretty sure we're
past 1 o'clock.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Sandra Charles: And
I would just like to--
after you asked your question and
get an answer, I'm going to ask one
of our other planning
partners, Dr. Tomoko Steen,
who was also in the science
business and technology division
and who was one of the
people who partnered with us.
She is an oncology pharmacist,
licensed both here and in Japan--
in New York and in
Japan, and a lecturer also
at Georgetown University.
So, I would like for her to
come forward after this question
to offer thanks to everyone
who participated in this,
and if you are able and willing
as people [inaudible]
questions thereafter.
Go ahead, Don.
>> Don Simons: That went on
so long I forgot my question.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just kidding.
No, I want to thank all of you,
like each one of us feel for the--
all the great works that
you're doing in terms of--
and treatment with immunotherapy,
immunotherapy and the research
that you're doing in terms of
collecting all the data to find
out who has, what, and how long
they've had it and prevention
in terms of screening and behaviors.
But one thing I didn't
hear anything about
and maybe a report addresses it,
and maybe a recommendations do,
is what's causing cancer.
In one particular area that I don't
think it has to do with behavior,
necessarily, that you hear about,
are toxins in our consumer products
and constant changes
in our environments.
And maybe there's more of a policy
question and a science question,
but is anything being
looked at in respect to that
and are there any recommendations
that are coming
out on how to address that?
>> Douglas Lowy: So, let me say
that one of our sister agencies,
part of the NIH, the
National Institute
for Environmental Health Sciences,
focuses on environmental
causes of cancer.
We look-- We support research in
that area as well as other aspects
of causes of cancer including
obesity, infections, and--
but when we look at
the different causes,
tobacco continues to
be front and center.
And when we think about, I mean, in
the context of the cancer Moonshot,
tobacco really ends up being
the thing that we focus
on when we're talking
about environmental causes,
one of the other recommendations,
because there is a vaccine
that can prevent cancers caused
by HPV infection emphasizing
uptake of the vaccine.
But really these other areas,
it's one of the reasons why it's
so important for us to
continue to be funded
for our other appropriations because
this is just one area where we need
to continue to do research
to uncover other important
environmental causes of cancer.
>> Sandra Charles: OK.
Do you have something, Juanita?
And Tomoko, in the
meantime, [inaudible].
>> Juanita Lyle: OK.
Just to go back over
survivorship, one [inaudible] for me
because I was the one-- chemo for
three years, the first protocol,
CML for two years, the
second protocol AC protocol,
and then intensive
three months radiation.
The aftermath of that, for
me, was a number of things.
For one thing, in 2012, because
my heart-- I had previously had,
what was called electrophysiology
ablation catheterization
to fix a very fast heartbeat.
I had that done.
And then in 2012, my
heart had dropped 18%.
And then my chambers were no
longer actually working together.
Also, my heart muscle was shut,
my electrical conduction was shut.
So I had to end up being implanted
with a pacemaker and defibrillator
which is what runs my heart, because
my heart no longer runs on its own.
So this was something that occurred.
Because my immunity system
was down, in 2013 I ended
up getting acute renal kidney
failure, and was wheeled out of here
and to the emergency room because
that dropped down to a five level.
So, all that to say, lymphedema is
with me, degenerating these diseases
with me, because I had radiation
was not monitored back then,
both my hands so I
have carpal tunnel
from the radiation as been proven.
And definitely loss of
memory when she's talking
about the brain situation, I
have some of those issues along
with the fact that what we
haven't touched upon is the fact
of PTSD in cancer patients.
So a lot of the times, the
younger you are it seems to be,
and we did something on
that here at the library,
because all these programs
that Dr. Charles is doing,
I partnered with her because of
the fact I've seen the need for us
to be able to have quality
lives in some way because I had
to create my quality life.
I had a good diet.
As I said, I had all the
right things but I ended
up getting advanced
stages in cancer.
So, all that to say,
that's why we're going
to have you all back
again and again.
And so, I'm going to
get this over to Tomoko
who partners with us as well.
>> Tomoko Steen: OK.
One thing that did-- was not
mentioned is cost of treatment,
especially immunotherapy, and
it's-- the evolution on treatment.
So, on behalf of all those
sponsoring organization
at the Library of Congress,
we'd like to thank excellent
panelists and excellent audience.
So, we hope we can do it,
you know, 2017, continuously.
And thank you so much
for coming, everyone.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.